[Music]
all right let's go out to
liz in mobile alabama hey liz what's
going on
hey drilling thanks for thanks for
speaking with me thank you so much for
giving me a shout
everybody doing well um yeah as best we
can
best we can oh okay fill me in so what's
going on
okay so i um
oh i'm a recently single mother of five
how recently coming uh in the it's been
a couple of weeks
um and we're kind of you know always
between
a rock and a hard place it seems this is
a
long-term uh domestic violence
relationship
oh man we were
never married we do have all of these
children in common they're all ours
okay um but it's come down to an
ultimatum
situation where we've separated and
gotten back together multiple times
before
sometimes in the midst of physical
violence sometimes not
but i feel more and more that i'm at my
breaking point with the
psychological uh turmoil
and also the logistics of now having to
you know provide four or five young
children
um after having for the most part been a
stay-at-home mother
for you know over 15 years
so you've been with the same person for
15 years you have five kids been
physically abusive this whole time
and you have had moments where you stood
up
tall and walked out and you circled back
and you circled back and you circled
back
and now you're worried about the
psychological impact
what was it about the physical impact
the physical abuse
that was okay for you
not so much that it was okay
i think it certainly came back to a
self-esteem issue
um and difficulty in childhood and
having
you know really realizing that worth
that i
don't deserve this and recently kind of
connecting
to a community for
the first time in many years enabled to
maintain friendships
and being exposed to other women or
other families that are experiencing you
know similar things and i was able to
get angry
yeah for them and then able to realize
well you know what i don't deserve this
either
no you absolutely don't and
your kids can't be around that
right right yeah and i realized
ultimately that becomes the stamp that
becomes the
imprint that becomes the picture of what
a normal relationship is because it's
the only one they know
right right and i realized that more and
more especially with my
older children the you know the
mimicking of
behaviors the learned behaviors and the
way that they interact and
you know it's set off red flag after red
flag in my mind like i know this
yeah i know this and i can't allow this
to perpetuate but on the other hand
being um you know essentially a
dependent for so long
um working out logistically how to care
for a family on my own
that's ultimately what has brought us
back is that i've
exhausted every resource tried to do
everything possible
and so i i want to pause there and i've
i've heard this over and over and it's
probably
one of the most tragic untold stories
in our culture which is
everyone knows the evils of physical and
psychological abuse
relational relationship abuse we all
know right even
the people experiencing the people who
have never seen it know
that's not right the other side of that
is i've heard over and over
especially by women experience physical
violence
with children who will say yeah but i
gotta eat
right yeah and there's nowhere to go and
so there
is this i this this terrifying sense of
being trapped right
yeah it's the lesser of the two evil
situation well okay are they going to be
happy
and safe and healthy but but they may
not have a roof over their heads because
you know what else what else could we do
this is the one thing
the one hold that he may have on us
ultimately is that financial support but
only if you're here with me
right that's right and it becomes the
demon you know and the demon you don't
know
and i just want to thank you for for
being brave and vulnerable there i i
know that there are so many folks who
will never experience the hell that
you've experienced
but can it's real easy to monday morning
quarterback that if that ever happened
to me
i would just yeah you don't know right
because it's terrifying if you've been
to stay at home
so how come you never married this guy
besides the obvious you know it was a
dream of mine for so long
um you know what girl doesn't want that
uh you know that that fairytale wedding
and
to marry the man of your dreams and to
have a healthy happy family with
children and all the things
um so who told you you weren't worth
that who told you you weren't worth that
i don't know that no anyone necessarily
expressed
that or made me feel that way but when
you know in the beginning
it you know it started off as we were
college students and with an unplanned
pregnancy and then it was just kind of
put off and put off and put off you had
a lot of excuses
yeah but somebody showed you somebody
gave you a picture of
a woman's worth at some point
where does that come from
i don't know if it's so much a woman's
worth or my words specifically but
growing up
i always felt less than um
there was something innately wrong with
me
um you know my my
father worked um you know quite a bit
was wonderful
supported the family um but he you know
worked in nine to five and sometimes
more and my mother was not
emotionally present okay um
when i started presenting as depressed
as an adolescent it was a problem
and it was something we had to keep
quiet and nobody could know about
it was difficult for me to find support
because of kind of the keeping up with
the jones's
dynamic and our family so your
the way you felt in the struggles that
were going on and the hell you were
living through
was something that you needed to figure
out how to keep a lid on
because we have other stuff to do yeah
and then you end up with an unplanned
pregnancy
and the way you feel about things and
the way you want to do things and the
fears and terror that you experience
that's something you need to put a lid
on
because we got stuff to do right yeah it
was it was very much a frying pan
to fire situation where you know i
finally found somebody that seemed
enamored and infatuated and thought i
was wonderful
and i felt special and loved for maybe
the first time
and then it when i realized what i'd
gotten myself into and what was
happening it was
it was too late it was too late but
you had five kids with him
that's a lot
so after child two after child three
tell me what you're thinking as you're
walking this road
this is something very um
probably one of the hardest struggles
that i deal with internally because you
know people are cute and they like to
say oh are they all yours
you know you know what causes that don't
you yes
but nobody sees through um i'm sorry
no you're good through the you know all
the facets of an abusive
relationship or coercive or manipulative
relationship
where
it's difficult to talk about things like
you know i know we're not actually
married but marital rape
or things where you feel like saying no
is not an option or maybe it will keep
the peace
or maybe now he'll be in a better mood
where it's obligation
um i didn't have the voice
nor the ability he's much much stronger
than i am
um yeah you know it's
and you know hearing these comments and
to no fault of these people who are
think they're being
you know funny or cute you know yeah we
have a television now yeah i took care
of it thank you
yeah they're mine
and they don't know the trauma on the
other side of it right yeah
right yeah yeah and so what was the
final straw that you said enough is
enough is enough
we've always kind of lived in a check to
check situation he's still
he runs his own business um
so we we've never you know we've always
struggled we've always uh
we owned a home briefly and then moved
and we've rented
for so long and the kids are always
we've moved many times the kids are
always very
unstable they say things like you know
at our next house or this or that or are
we going to move soon because i really
don't want to leave my friends or this
or that
really when i realized how deep
i have very little control over finances
if any um and when i realized
that he was kind of perpetually making
these excuses keeping us in the
situation
we were going without because of
selfishness
um things like this and that in
combination with
the name calling the criticizing just
the anger
and the yelling the kids i noticed that
they would disappear
go to hide you know kind of slowly slink
away and i said
we can't do this yeah i can't um
he actually was the one that gave me an
ultimatum you know unless you get your
stuff together and start taking care of
me like
it's your job to do it to make me happy
i'm not moving again with you and i said
okay so this is the first time we've
ever been on the same page
um and that's fine so go ahead and he he
you know ultimately did um
decided he wasn't gonna fulfill his
financial obligations as far as basic
living expenses and
and you know let the chips fall where
they may which ended up in us
having to leave our home and so he was
able to take care of his end and get his
own
home for the family which the family has
never lived in and we
stay in a for the last couple weeks
we've been in a pop-up camper
in a friend's backyard and i'm trying to
scramble
and do figure out what i can yeah
um but there's always that looming if
things get bad enough we may have to go
back and figure and regroup and i just i
don't want to go there again
yeah so do you have a any sort of
church community friend community that
will give your kids
a house for two months three months
or has there been any sort of um
connection with the women's shelter
there in your local area
that will take everybody in y'all can't
stay in a backyard pop-up camper not
five kids
um i you know i'm well acquainted with
women's shelters in our area
i've been i've stayed there um
once for quite some time a couple of
years ago
and ultimately this is the what's
unfortunate
is although they have as many resources
as they do
they do what they can they help so many
families and women i saw so many people
come in and out
the ultimately what they can do
is limited especially for families of
this size
with no financial savings or no job
prospects
it's just starting everyone
from square one and sometimes it's just
most of the time maybe all of the time
it's just not
possible yeah um that's what i found so
what about your friends and community
or even if you have to say three of them
go to this house for a while and two
go to this house um you got to get those
those kids under a roof that's that's
where they're safe and i know you know
that i'm not trying to pile on
i'm trying to encourage okay yeah
yeah no i i i you know that breaks my
heart to think about
um
having to separate them uh that's i know
certainly probably one of my other
hang-ups is
you know so you know why didn't
think of it this way what you are
and it makes so much sense and i can't
think of any more
pure heart here so i'm i'm walking
alongside you okay this isn't a finger
wagging thing this is just me
is you're trying the best you can
to keep the picture of a family that you
have had in your head since you were a
little bitty kid
intact
and that is on fire right
and so yeah absolutely there comes
moments of i like walking hand in hand
with
my two kids and my wife but if the house
is on fire
everybody's got to get out in the yard
and i've got to run into the house and
get as much stuff out into the front
yard as possible
right because it's an emergency and of
course
nobody's going to separate your family
long term no chance no how no way
not under liz's watch right that's not
the kind of mama you're going to be
right
right yeah but in an effort to
hold this picture together so tightly
because there's so little in your world
you can
control right because you've got a an
abusive
evil person who has created a universe
for you where you've got
nothing right and so in an effort to
control you can control you hold on to
this picture really tight
and suddenly you find yourself in a
camper in a backyard
with five little kids trying to finish
out a school year on the back end of a
pandemic
and it's it's
it's that that picture's cracking and
cracking and you're just gonna hold
tighter and tighter and tighter
right so there's comes moments when
it's okay to exhale and say
billy and tommy you all are gonna go
stay with the smiths and i'm gonna see
you every single day
and the other three are going to go stay
with so and so
and i'm going to stay with you all too
and because things are on fire
and i'm going to have to work like crazy
to find me a job of some sort
you are gonna have to start from square
one and this is hard
and it's awful and it's wrong
and it's easy for me to say you need to
get the authorities involved
that's my recommendation but i also know
that makes you even less safe
right and when somebody's i mean that is
when somebody's got their own go ahead
i'm sorry it is it is just so difficult
because we have been here
before where you know through we do have
a church community it is
you know a small congregation um but
they were able to bless
us several years ago and we were able to
find our own
home and we did well well not well we
got by
for several months almost a year and i
found
then that even working full-time and
then some
and taking advantage of subsidized child
care for my youngest ones and
you know public school for the rest and
day care i
worked as much as i possibly could had a
couple
of side hustles even and even so at the
end of the month
there were more you know there was
at the end of the money we still had
bills yeah you know if i was
i was taking a little bit from savings
every month and a little bit more and a
little bit more until eventually it was
just gone
yeah and he was able to come in like
save the day the savior that is his
personality type
you know how i have this house then we
can be a family
yeah and i felt like i did not have
another option
have you sat down with me now post
pandemic when
housing prices are through the roof
almost doubled what they were a year ago
in this area
yeah um it seems just hopeless like i am
crazy to be thinking that i can do this
you're not you're not
um have you sat down with the police and
an attorney
to get child support so that that money
that he needs to be paying comes without
him
i have it's very it's very convoluted
and when i said i've exhausted every
resource i'm not being flippant i really
mean
over the past several years um you know
like i said when you own a business
a lot of unfortunately a lot of it is
off the books
a lot exactly cash taxes are
not um an accurate representation by a
long shot of income
uh child support has been a joke
um and that's that those are the things
that
you have to have to lean on oh yeah
yeah i understand if it was accurate i
feel like we could maybe
just slide under just make it but it's
just um
i'm not even sure how to go about
it's it's a matter of time for example
for five kids you know a monthly payment
of four hundred dollars
is wonderful yeah that's where we're at
exactly that's where getting with an
attorney who will do a forensic account
accounting of his resources right
that's where you may consider taking all
five kids and moving in
with a sister who's in colorado or
somewhere across the country
that's where you pick up and you start
looking at where are places where
women in your situation are taken care
of better than they are in your local
community
and what i'm talking about stepping out
and looking and saying i've got to
rebuild this thing from the floor up and
you got to change the oil
on this car while it's moving right
right absolutely and so here's what i
want you to do i want you to begin to
think of this as
a two to three to five year
project not a two month project and i
know that sounds so flippant it feels so
overwhelming
that's where you can sit down and
especially get somebody to walk
alongside you
who will help you build out here's what
a budget's going to look like
hey attorney i need you to know that
this is how my husband does
business he runs stuff under the table
it's not cash
i can point you to some of the people
who pay him on how he's actually
living you can go do a forensic account
so what they'll do is they'll look at
the things he actually buys
the money that flows through not just
the taxable income
and they'll come up with a full picture
of what he makes
and that's how you can get in and find
out or get
the child support up to where it needs
to be and then what most
scumbags in that situation do is they'll
literally take less
clients so they'll have to pay less
right
and so it's a game of cat and mouse the
big thing here is
do you go back to school do you sit down
with your church and say over the next
nine months the next
year here's where i'm going to be can
y'all help me out
is there a couple of folks who at your
local church or your local group or
wherever your mom lives or wherever your
sister lives
and i'm making people up here right that
would be willing to help out with
babysitting in exchange for
fill in the blank um and so you're
talking about a long
term play and there is unfortunately
no um
there's no happy ending of this tomorrow
or a month from now or three months from
now
what you do know is what happens when
you go back
right right and
i mean on the one on the one side i
completely understand that there's no
quick fix it's going to be a lifelong
honestly a lifelong healing
for everybody it's going to be a
constant process but we're going to move
towards getting better
and i have on the other hand been
in the alternative for over a decade so
i know yeah exactly i know it's i know
it's time and it's a process right
it's i think the one thing that holds me
back
is you know on the one hand the
crippling anxiety
um and it's you know the overwhelming
these the sheer overwhelmingness of it
of all of the things not only figuring
out the living situation the money the
guilt over asking
for so many things from so many people i
need help here and help there
um but also managing the needs of you
know
children that aren't school age yet the
ones that are
that want to do you know why can't i do
sports why can't i go to a friend's
house
i need help with my homework but i you
know the fear of not being there because
i'm gonna have to work so hard
yeah um in addition you know to
being mother to all of them um so listen
and not have me
resent me and say well you know things
are better with dad
and that's where i want you to always be
leaning towards a long game you're
playing here
okay here's why there will come a moment
when your kids will turn back and you
will become
the maternal figure that changed the
trajectory of this family
you and there will come a season when
your kids will turn
and look at the sacrifices you made
and the unbearably
guilt-ridden conversations you had to
have or that you
asked somebody to have on your behalf
that allowed them to be where they are
now
and that's why i need you
the only thing i'm going to ask of you
number one is don't go back
ask furiously do what you've got to do
to ask furiously for help reach out to
resources
just start banging a gong on the street
okay
and i want you to call your church's
bluff and if they say who they say they
are
then they should rally around you it
helps for you to have some very clear
needs
one of those needs for instance is i
need somebody to go ask the local little
league
if they have a scholarship program for
kids who's
and i guarantee you somebody in your
church who doesn't have a lot of money
but
loves a good deal will get on the phone
and make sure that your kids are playing
little league this summer
and somebody who needs some i will be
the best
i will be the i'll make cookies i will
do whatever
i don't have money to pay kids
for babysitting but i will write the
best
letters of recommendation i will fill in
the blank because you've got so much
value to offer
you've been what you've been navigating
you would be a
you would be a thunderdome lawyer
right you would be an incredible navy
seal i hung out with jocko this past
week
you can stand next to him okay
you are um a powerful strong
woman the person who's got to believe
that is you
and i want the people and you gotta have
some space to breathe so you can even
see it
right and so here's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna do a couple of things for you
first thing is um for the listeners who
don't know i work here at ramsey
solutions i'm gonna give you a year
of ramsay plus here's what that here's
here's why that's important people are
going to ask like that's got all the
financial peace university
it's a budgeting thing and i know you're
saying i don't have any money to even
budget
i get that when things feel
super overwhelming it feels like
everything's raining and i can't figure
out what
what thing to do next what's the bucket
to put where
that's exactly right and the roof is
caving in oh and the in the
in the front door's on fire right what
this does is it breaks down chaos
into a step-by-step by step
plan bus particularly with your money
but more importantly than that
it gives you a plan for intentionality
for your whole life
so at the same time you're playing a
five year game you're also playing a
minute by minute game
and liz it's exhausting and so i want
you to
reach out to folks in your church and
say i need a day
i need two hours a week where i can just
breathe i need
fill in the blank i need to fill up like
this will help you break down your needs
step by step by step i'm going to send
you a copy of my book redefining anxiety
yeah for all this we're going to send it
to you for free and i want you to go
back to it and go back to it here's the
thing
you're crippling anxiety it means your
brain is working great
it means everything is firing on all
cylinders your body's been telling you
for years you're not safe
and you know this right yeah yeah where
it gets hard is you haven't valued
yourself
and now suddenly you're starting to
realize my kids aren't safe and you
value them
right and that makes all of my world
mutt exactly exactly
and so you've got some really hard
choices on the horizon what i want to
tell you is if your kids are playing a
little league
that somebody else helped you get for
free while you're out going back to
school
or you're out working and then going
back to school and somebody else is
helping tuck your kids in at night
and they're just a saint and you're
thinking i can never pay you i can never
repay you i can never repay you
or there's two grandmothers at your
church who are rotating or two granddads
who are rotating
helping out because it's they've set
themselves up in their world where this
is the kind of
joy they get to spread into the world
you're going to have to open your hands
and accept it and for the first time in
your life you're going to have to
understand that you're worth that that's
that's that type of support
you didn't get it from your family you
didn't get it from this loser that
you've been with for 15 years
and at some point you have to look in
the mirror and say behalf of my kids
i've got to understand that i got value
even if for a while you have to fake it
and pretend you have value
so you can teach your kids what value
looks like right
because they're looking to you and say
what does value look like
right and so sometimes it means dropping
your shoulders and saying hey i need
help
and you need a lot less right you need a
lot
oh yeah and then i want you to find
somebody in your community that's going
to be a lawyer that's going to help you
go to war
and i tell you i know lawyers they live
for some these moments
oh these make them so happy they sit
there and work on
contracts and nonsense day after day
punching that six minute clock over and
over
and then a woman who's been beat down
and abused
and has five kids um because her husband
is evil
and needs some help oh they start
licking their chops on this one
right those that support and that help
is there
it's going to start with you getting
really really clear about tiny
bite-sized chunks tiny bite-sized steps
you can take day after day after day
today i want you to call somebody that
will sit down and help you make a plan
for finding housing for your kids
i want you to stay on the line we're
going to get you these financial
resources these intentionality resources
and they have everything in this it's
got the budgeting stuff but it also has
where do i buy the cheapest fill in the
blank how do i
make a deal on this deal what happens
when my car goes out it's got a
step-by-step plan for all these
different processes
and we'll teach you how to get on a
budget teach you how to be intentional
right i want you to sit down with
somebody today and help them
help them help you make a plan for your
kids they got to be under a roof they
got to have showers you got to have
plumbing
you can't be in a pop-up camper with
five children
i can't be with my well never mind
you're just a stud you're incredible and
you have value
you've got worth and i want you to know
you've got a whole country of people
rallied around you
we need to know what you need okay and
if you live in this
area mobile alabama i want you and
somebody comes knocking on your door
you're going to open it you're going to
welcome people in because that's what we
do
that's where we're at as a country we've
got to start welcoming people in
and if you're listening to this and
you're an abusive person
and you lord over people with violence
you load over people with
fix my house you lure over people with
rape and power today you're done
you're done enough
go with the help you need stop it's
generational
you're not that important stop
no actually you know what you are that
important
we need no more of it enough liz thank
you for being brave
call anytime you need something and we
will be here the best we can help you
with
then i want you to put your church on
notice why don't you put your community
on notice that liz needs some support
and then you're going to be about
changing this thing from the inside out
and you're going to look up in five
years and 10 years
and you'll have a group of kids five
kids that are growing up
understanding their mom as a rock star
there is a light at the end of this
tunnel it's gonna be a long walk but
there's a light there and you can't
do it alone thank you so much for your
call liz